mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
es ist das ritual aller tv rituale die
krimireihe die seit 50 jahren das ende
der woche markiert das gesellschaftliche
kaminfeuer bei dem sich die fangemeinde
länder und generationenübergreifend vor
dem bildschirm versammelt die heilige
sonntags coo der tatort
herzlich willkommen bei kulturplatz
unser tatort heute heißt tourias folter
denn hier am rande des industriegebiets
blicken wir heute hinter die kulissen
des neuen schweizer tatort
[Musik]
und so werde ich dann auch bereits
erwartet vom neuen helvetischen
ermittlerinnen du
[Musik]
so so dass sie welche kraft es
funktioniert daher möchte ich jetzt mal
ausprobieren ob das funktioniert das ist
carol schuler
sie spielt ermittlerin testen leben
steht sie auf der berliner schaubühne
und sie singt mit eigener band ihre
tatort partnerin ist ein aperitif alias
isa branche gab sie bekannt von bühne
und film und ebenfalls musikalisch sie
ist ausgebildete pianistin jetzt sitzen
wir schon in der kaffee ecke die also
essentiellen krimis wir haben uns auf
stützen geeinigt carol schuler du
spielst tessa ort die neue ermittlerin
profilerin im team zürich wer ist die
was das für eine type das ist eine type
die vom zürichberg
ob ein hund und sie kommt aus einer
wohlhabenden familie und sehr
einflussreich auch die eltern sind in
der politik und so aber sie hat zur
rebellischen charakter würde ich sagen
ist schon in jungen jahren da
ausgestiegen und ausgebrochen und aus
diesem goldenen käfig und dann über
umwege bei der polizei gelandet
aber das schöne bei der figur finde ich
ja dass die sich immer ein bisschen
unsicher ist ob sie da wirklich wichtig
ist jetzt auch so eine hausbesetzer
vergangenheit und deswegen es ist
manchmal schwierig für sie das jetzt
wirklich eine polizistin ist ein
zielkonflikt schnell genau das ist immer
so staatsgewalt und anarchie das ist das
was bei ihr so aufeinander trifft la
peri zürcher weil es die westschweizerin
isa vancouver also sie kommt aus live
und aus seiner arbeiterfamilie
polizeischule sofort gemacht um geld zu
verdienen und jus studiert und soll sie
ist so perfektionist sie glaubt nur
fakten und das ist die man das problem
mit
die emotionale ja aber so kurz corp corp
kann man nicht sagen nein überhaupt
nicht wir sind beide sehr gut und sehr
bald genau ich glaube das ist nicht so
schwarz weiß gezeichnet das interessante
an der beziehung können uns ein bisschen
umschauen könnte mich herum führen hier
alles anfassen da du darfst alles
anfassen
ich war ja voll auf so was rein immer
also ich habe geglaubt das ist so ein
richtiges büro was man halt gekapert hat
für den dreh ist echtes kommt ja ja ja
hast du das ganze studio wurde eingebaut
da sind unsere plätze
das ist hier isabels bild ja ich will
dann will ich auch ein bisschen ein
cowboy findig und deswegen passt das
sehr gut
das ist hier testers schreibtisch da
brennt es normalerweise die waffe
gewesen ja eine andere branche hier ist
eigentlich 104 meine waffe weil sie der
taschenrechner ist haben sie in
sicherheit gebracht ich habe ein foto
mit carla del ponte und carla del ponte
es mit an bord weiß sie dass jetzt schon
isabel grosjean hat mit ihr
zusammengearbeitet und ich bin
eigentlich eine sehr große fantasie
[Gelächter]
spielt sie vielleicht mal mit kommt dass
man weiß was es war so geil ich weiß
nicht nein nein ich weiß nicht aber das
war super ich möchte gern eine szene
vitali nicht dann mit dir kannst dir
jetzt gemacht
[Gelächter]
oder es feueralarm ich durfte ja schon
gucken was man sagen kann er zwei seid
euch nicht so heute findet euch nicht so
cool ich glaube dieser beil hat ein
bisschen probleme mit tessa weil sie
sehr junges und sehr grün hinter den
ohren und direkt als mord ermittlerin
bei leib und leben einsteigt was sehr
unüblich ist und deswegen gibt es den
berechtigten verdacht dass sie diesen
job nur durch vitamin b bekommen hat und
das ist natürlich schwierig für isabell
weil sie sehr hart arbeiten musste für
alles in ihrem leben und tessa viele
einfach in die wiege gelegt bekommen hat
und das birgt natürlich
konfliktpotenzial
und eigentlich isabel fühlt dass es ein
problem gibt sie weiß nicht was in
erster fall man sieht es nicht aber es
kommt noch was das dunkle geheimnis und
alles fängt an mit einer verkohlten
leiche erster arbeitstag für tessa ort
aus kurzer distanz den ort sind ein
einsatz wäre es in sich hat laut
regisseurin vivian andere ecken war
zuerst kein frauenduo angedacht sondern
eine weibliche und eine männliche
hauptrolle
glaubt gott wie weniger darum dass man
jetzt da alles so frauenquote nach die
bürste geht das am besten macht die
premierengäste zustell beiden
funktioniert und die als komplette
bezüge zwischen schutz zauber des antrat
etwas der psychotherapie weiter zurück
symbolik selbst unser opfer seien da
passiert ist
die ermittlungen führen zurück in zürich
der 1980 er jahre in die explosive zeit
der jugend cup an
alte bekannte aus der punkszene geraten
ins visier
[Musik]
sind opel ist fertig
auflehnung gegen das establishment
anarchie ein metier in dem sich die
regisseurin selbst gut auskennt es ist
so wie sie früher relativ lange bank
schieben also 10 in syrien in basel
und da ist sie bezug zu der szene keine
die dortige ja aber dann sah ich sie mir
es ist mir sehr nah sie die ganze nur
die ganz nach dem wunsch nach aufbruch
der wunsch nach frieden
die themen die hat sich eine andere die
krawalle der 1980 er jahre holen auch
die verdächtigen ein
ins zentrum der ermittlungen gerät unter
anderem ein drogenabhängiger freund von
thessa ob auch er damals in die jugend
krawalle verwickelt
der fall nimmt plötzlich an fahrt auf
als der polizeikommandant an einem apéro
ein unerwartetes geschenk erhält
die lieferung lässt erahnen
dem duo grosjean rott steht noch einiges
bevor
[Musik]
bei der stoffentwicklung hat man ja mit
der kapo zürich zusammen gearbeitet wie
sie ihr konntet ihr euch in die figur
bildung mit einbringen ja wir hatten das
glück dass unsere drehbuchautoren stefan
brunner und lorenz langenegger sehr eine
detaillierte figuren bibel schon
vorgelegt haben als sie haben sich
glaube ich drei jahre oder so oder
wirklich sehr lange zeit haben die diese
figuren entspannen und sehr detailliert
schon geschrieben was ist deren
hintergrund denn humor deren dunkle
geheimnisse was auch immer aber trotzdem
konnten wir auch echt gut uns noch
einbringen haben sehr eng mit den
reparaturen zusammengearbeitet und das
thema nochmal überarbeitet und unsere
eigene farbe sozusagen nach eingebracht
also normalerweise diese tatort
kommissare die habe ich mir so einen
bestimmten lebensentwurfs visite
isabelle forschung aus eigentlich sie
möchte die chef sein aber es ist auch
weil sie wenn sie in den haag gearbeitet
hat hat sie verstanden das als muss die
chefin sein um wirklich was zu ändern
und
deswegen nicht nur weil sie nach oben
gehen will
aber ich weiß nicht ja sie will gute
arbeit machen sie will die welt dann
eigentlich dort auch bei tester es ist
glaube ich so karriere ist nicht
wirklich ein konzept was in ihrem kopf
vorkommt das liegt vielleicht auch daran
dass es nie musste sie mussten die
wirklich arbeiten und was ich an ihm mag
ist dass sie halt sie sie ist immer so
auf der suche ist ziemlich durchlässig
und kommt dadurch auch an die leute ran
aber das ist bei der polizei natürlich
dann manchmal auch schwierig als vor und
nachteile
aber ich denke mal die ergänzen sich
dadurch ganz gut
schauen wir noch weiter drücken ist auch
noch im raum
ihr wisst ja um diesen massiven
kultfaktor also manchmal schauen da bis
zu zehn millionen zuschauer
seit 50 jahren gibt es den tatort seit
30 jahren mit unterbruch ist auch die
schweiz mit an bord und hierzulande gibt
es dann auch immer mal ein bisschen
harsche kritik hat fast schon tradition
könnte man meinen
langweilig klischiert warum wird es mit
euch besser aber wir wissen aber nicht
ob es bereits wir lassen uns überraschen
ich glaube man muss da mit den kritiken
irgendwie ein bisschen aufpassen und
vielleicht auch nicht alles lesen
ich dachte mir schon vielleicht stelle
ich jemanden an der wir nur die guten
kritiken zu schräg dass ich die anderen
gar nicht lesen
es gibt immer leute die mögen leute die
nicht mögen das ist normal
ja und ich weiß auch nicht ob die
schlechten kritiken von luzern hat hat
und so berechtigt waren als sie haben ja
echt gute fälle auch gemacht zum teil
und vielleicht ist es auch so ein
bisschen ein hobby geworden
tatort bashing zu betreiben aber da
müssen wir jetzt durch
da müsst ihr durch es gibt die guten und
die weniger guten fälle aber der
schweizer tatort ist nicht totzukriegen
luzern schauplatz des schweizer tatorts
in den vergangenen neun jahren im
einsatz der ungeduldige und hartnäckige
reto flückiger verkörpert von stefan
gubser und die ausgleichende kommissarin
des tschad alias delia mayer
meist spielen die crimson einen
gesellschaftlich relevanten kontext
sterbehilfe rassismus schmiergeldaffären
er ist produziert jährlich zwei folgen
im verbund mit ard und orf
im gegenzug gibt es deren beliebte
tatorte gleichzeitig ist es für user war
aber interessantes schweizer filmbranche
meint interessant die hand mit dem
pflegeheim dass wir zweimal im jahr auch
informer potenzieller publikum wo zehn
millionen liegt ist die talent ist das
könne zeige und hätte große
aufmerksamkeit in deutschland und das
ist ein tolles format und wie sie der
tatort ist deutschlands populärstes
fernsehformat die schweizer folgenden
gegen sind beim deutschen publikum wie
auch bei kritikern nicht so beliebt
ihr einsatz der schweizer tatort raskob
sogar im wortsinn durchschnittlichkeit
ich bin zu beurteilen das hat durchaus
feld womit die maßgeblich zur unter den
17 es hat aber herausragende beispiele
wo wirklich wie tweed über das mittelmaß
gefragt sind und die ambition henry
mag.a psychologie und lunge ich denke
eine von der leitstelle die musik stirbt
zuletzt
einzige stetig das ganze krell von dani
levy meisterhaft inszeniert das ist ein
tatort wo sportgeschichte geschrieben
noch nie vorher dafür gab es einen
griechischen kreis aber die tiefste
quote aller folgen 2018
die hochdorf und schickt mir gesessen
ist
sie hat das auge erkennen
christine hämmerling hat in ihrer
doktorarbeit erforscht weshalb der
schweizer tatort beim deutschen publikum
schlechter ankommt also ein wichtiger
punkt ist sicherlich die sprache dass
man als aus deutscher perspektive findet
das klingt doch jetzt merkwürdig denn
die personen doch in der schweiz sind
und aber irgendwie weder schwyzerdütsch
noch wirklich hochdeutsch sprechen und
dann kann man sich manchmal noch eine
die synchronisation schwierigkeiten an
den lippen erkennen mit dem kreuz etwas
passiert das blog die frau nie das sage
ich dir es hat geheißen sie sei im
moment stabil
lokalkolorit wird von der ard gewünscht
welche rolle die sprache des beispiels
wird immer wieder diskutiert
bitte schließt wird so dass der häufige
regen zuspruch reduziert und den wünscht
man sich eine person ist seriös
schweizerisches hochdeutsch wo mir
wieder findet nein das macht die suche
oder oder sich als schauspieler und sich
so präsentieren
mit derart verbucht und das ist
tatsächlich eines einzigen darunter
geführt mit der ard in der schweiz
hingegen und der tatort eine
erfolgsgeschichte die episoden aus
luzern erreichten einschaltquoten von
über 30 prozent über den unterschied
deutlich grundsätzlich schlechter aus
die deutsche tatort wenn man verrückt
der merkt man dass deutschland sehr viel
produziert wird und es sind einzelne
folgen
dazu zählte aller erste schweizer tatort
howald fall
mathias gnädinger spielt 1990 an den
kommissar der zugleich auch täter ist
der film mit seinem ungewöhnlichen ende
ist ein kracher
mehr als elf millionen menschen schauen
sich in deutschland diesen tatort an
verteidiger kommt ahnt er zog dieser
wird nach nur zwei folgen abgelöst durch
lászló kövér zusammenarbeiten
zwölf episoden lang spielt der schweizer
tatort in bis das schweizer fernsehen
2002 aus finanziellen gründen müssten
verbund aussteigt ich habe neun jahre
später und jetzt aus luzern ist es
wieder dabei sofia milos csi miami soll
klemmer in flückigers dezernat bringen
doch der neustart misslingt aus
qualitätsgründen wird der film
ungeschnitten die ausstrahlung
verschoben los gehts chefermittler
flückiger bleibt acht jahre und 17
folgen lang bis auch flückigers zeit
2009/10 abgelaufen ist nun zügelt der
tatort nach zürich ich glaube das hilft
vielleicht wirklich ursächlich schlechte
image in deutschland los zu werden mit
dem neustart und das sind alles grün
us-sparte zurückführt hinter dem seite
traum
er probiert mit dem neue tatort neues
format neue stadt neuer ermittler und
die heimat und durch die frau ist und
mir hoffe dass man das ziel erreicht das
wir in deutschland wirklich dass man
wieder in die schweiz natürlich erfolge
sind aber dass man mit deutschland
herzen von publikum erobert wo ist ihre
dienstwaffe rolle spielt
[Musik]
steht wieder alles kaputt isabell ist
der waffen profi ja ich war ziemlich
gute am schießen und forschung
ich hab was vor hinsetzen anna hast du
als westschweizerin bevor eine neue
ermittlerin gesucht wurde überhaupt
schon mal ein tatort geguckt
carol gehörst du selbst zum tatort fan
club nein man kann es hier dich weiter
laufen
was macht anna zur guten schauspielerin
caroline ihre durchlässigkeit glaube ich
und ihre ihre tiefe also wir haben
zusammen
das erste casting gehabt und wir mussten
diese einer streitszene spielen und ich
hatte wirklich das gefühl man konnte so
durch ihre augen in ihre seele gucken
auch wenn sie es nicht zeigt man spürt
wirklich was in ihr vorgeht und ich war
sehr berührt beim casting von ihrem
spiel
es war soll ich lügen oder was vater der
mittleren zu sein bedeutet ein stück
weit auch ein festes einkommen warum ist
carol ihr geld wert
sie kann alles machen alles sie kann
singen malen spielen engagieren france
was hat tessa und wirst du auch gerne
hättest glaube sie geht in situation
rein und ohne sich viele gedanken
darüber zu machen was die konsequenzen
sind kann auch gefährlich sein aber sie
ist angstfrei das hätte ich auch gerne
welche marke hat isabell korrosion von
dir geerbt ja es ist perfektionist das
kann positiv und negativ sein
sie hat nicht viel geduld ich denke
manchmal die sachen müssen schnell sein
so ich weiß nicht was genau ich gehe
einfach in ihre
socken würden wir sagen auch französisch
oder apropos sorgten jetzt musst du sie
mal zeigen meine sorgte her sieht man ja
dass immer noch ernstes vorher womit
hast du schon das gesetz gebrochen
manchmal ich bezahle in meinem parking
nicht aber es ist nichts extra weißt du
ich muss ich bin immer zu spät und dann
vergisst vergess ich sonst nein gar
nicht
mein anwalt donald trump oder joe biden
joe biden klar ja tatort usa um den
kommen wir auch in der heutigen sendung
nicht darum stehen wir doch kurz vor den
us präsidentschaftswahlen seit monaten
verfolgen wir ihn mit diesen mitunter
würdelosen wahlkampf mit beleidigungen
unterstellungen und bemerkenswerten
inszenierungen wir haben einen
journalisten getroffen
der sehr genau hingeschaut und hingehört
hat einen wahlkampf ermittler sozusagen
kaum von seiner corona virus erkrankung
erholt betreibt donald trump sofort
wieder wahlkampf
lasst euch nicht davon dominiert hat
keine angst davor
rasiert hatte er seine kampagne bereits
vor 16 monaten
heute abend stehe ich hier vorliegen und
meine kandidatur für eine zweite
amtszeit als präsident bekannt zu geben
das war der moment für zwei deutsche
journalisten eine recherchereise durch
die politlandschaft der usa zu starten
um diesen wahlkampf in misch- und
schriftlich zu dokumentieren
ein zentrales thema bringt es sich
sofort auf johns creek gegen die medien
das ist eine lüge von den fake news da
hinten
die autoren haben mit dutzenden insidern
gesprochen auch mit chance berater
sebastian gorka wenn sie als
journalisten nicht die wahrheit erzählt
sondern propaganda betreiben
macht sie das zum freund er war heiß und
feind des amerikanischen volkes
es geht nicht um die medien sondern um
die lügen chris verdrehung von tatsachen
die formierung und kriegsrhetorik das
innenpolitische klima der usa ist
vergiftet so die autoren
wir treffen co autor klaus brinkbäumer
in seiner zeitweisen wahlheimat new york
die ruhe trügt denn in den usa tobt die
wahlschlacht trump hat sehr schnell
gesehen und ich habe das bei vielen
wahlkampfveranstaltungen erlebt das
funktioniert dass die beschimpfung der
medien somit das populärste ist was er
tun kann dort also wenn er das hat etwas
beängstigendes wenn man als journalist
da hinten steht und vorne der präsident
der usa ruft julia sude den i miev the
people trump hat im gespräch mit steve
bennett seinem ehemaligen berater die
strategie entwickelt medien zum
feindbild zu erklären weil beide bahnen
und tram gesehen haben das funktioniert
bei den anhängern trumps dieses ständige
diffamieren und anklagen sorgt für einen
glaubwürdigkeitsverlust und das hat
trump instrumentalisiert und
vorangetrieben ich glaube dass es ein
strategisches element gibt das sagten
uns jedenfalls leute im weißen haus
er nimmt damit allen enthüllungen die
kommen werden und die auch tatsächlich
gekommen sind die kraft weil er immer
sofort sagen ja fällt müssen
stimmt ja sowieso nicht und ich hab's
euch gesagt das sind die volksfeinde und
die wollen mich weghaben
die konservativen wie die liberalen
medien profitieren davon weil sie
täglich neue schlagzeilen für die
schlammschlacht geliefert bekommen und
so ihre auflagen hoch treiben können
eine art permanentes herzrasen
diagnostizieren die beiden journalisten
eine nation die im wahn gefangen sein
sie nennen es die amerikanische
katastrophe der politische gegner ist
ein todfeind und und jain weit verdient
der vernichtung das ist die sprache die
hier angewandt wird das hat etwas
wahrhaftes verbotes manisches all diese
begriffe sind hart aber sie treffen auf
die usa von 2020 erklärte im märz zwar
den pandemie notstand überließ aber
unpopuläre maßnahmen wie locker und
seinen politischen gegnern nur um ihnen
dann panikmache vorzuwerfen und seine
anhänger zum widerstand anzustacheln
entsprechend stöhr sabotieren
konservative seit monaten landesweit
jegliche schutzvorkehrungen und
einschränkungen im alltagsleben
republikaner oder republikanerin zu sein
bedeutet ist ich trage keine masken das
ist meine persönliche freiheit
einschränkt es gibt auch den klimawandel
nicht die waldbrände in kalifornien
haben damit nichts zu tun ich bin gegen
abtreibung ich bin gegen steuern für die
republikaner gehört permanente
abgrenzung zum parteiprogramm
während die proteste gegen rassistische
polizeigewalt rund um den fall floyd
hochkochten feierte der präsident in
florida einen raketenstart und
verunglimpfte in lhasa zentrum alle
protestierenden pauschal das andenken an
george freut wir sind eher von chaoten
plünderern und anarchisten wie desolat
die autoren die lage der amerikanischen
nation einschätzen machen die
kapitelüberschriften im buch deutlich
die schlimmste erkenntnis oder die
traurigste erkenntnis ist dass die
amerikanische katastrophe wie es wie wir
es nennen
im zusammentreffen diverser krisen liegt
es gibt eine pandemie die in eine
wirtschaftskrise gemündet hat es gibt
einen wirklichen bildungsnotstand in den
usa es gibt eine infrastruktur die man
gar nicht mehr so nennen kann eine reine
also ganz brüchig ja es gibt eine die
unterversorgung oder den freien fall
viel an millionen von menschen hier und
eine politische handlungsunfähigkeit
also wirkliche dysfunktional i tät weil
parteien in washington es nicht mehr
schaffen die einfachsten gesetze
durchzubringen oder die simpelsten
kompromisse zu finden
wir schaffen es nicht jetzt in der
pandemie den eigenen bürgern zu helfen
hysterische hektik bestimmt den tools
der us gesellschaft sie ist zum
spielfeld geworden für machtpolitik
voller liegen und angstmacherei bleibt
noch hoffnung
die handlungsunfähigkeit ist das was ich
wirklich erschreckend finde weil es mir
ein mensch schwer fällt zu sehen wie die
usa da wieder herausfinden wollen
das ist die gefährlichste wahl die wir
je hatten
damit könnte trump für einmal etwas
wahres gesagt haben
so dann gehe ich wieder was mir übrigens
aufgefallen ist es gibt keine
lederjacken
ja stimmt super wäre ja wir wollten uns
nicht auf jedes klischee draufsetzen
es gibt schon genug ermittlern die eine
jede lederjacke haben oder das machen
wenigstens das anderen wenigstens das
damit war das auch erklärt vielen da sie
den einblick und bis bald
ok back to business
[Musik]
kommenden sonntag den 18 oktober ist es
also soweit um 20 uhr startet die
premiere zur iba und nächste woche drei
mittels eva wannenmacher bei jungen
kunstschaffenden an der jungkunst
winterthur und hier geht es weiter mit
der zweiten staffel der handmade state
[Musik]
über den mund wir blicken hinter die
kulissen vom neuen schweizer tatort mit
[Musik]
sehr gut
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
tourismus
[Musik]